I'm very excited about this I wish we
had not only a stoicism week but an
Aristotle week and a Plato a week and
all sorts of weeks like that that would
be the coolest thing ever in in
philosophy Hegel we could be pretty cool
too right today begins stoical week 2014
which runs from the 24th of November in
2014 to the 30th that's a Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday set of events there is a course
out there which you can still I think
sign up for I'm enrolled in it myself
I'm not the only philosopher enrolled in
it there there's a few other people as
well and then tons of people who just
have some sort of interest in stoicism
students lifelong learners it's just a
wonderful course setting that these
people at the University of Exeter have
put together and developed over the last
several years as they've been
celebrating stoical week this is
something that I didn't do anything with
in the past and kind of regretted I
wanted to get involved with it last year
but I found myself too busy this year I
thought maybe I'll do some some events
but again got get married this is the
month of November I am going to be
shooting videos each day including this
video right here but I'll talk more
about the videos a little bit later but
I decided I want to get involved in this
class because it seemed like such a cool
idea I wanted to see what I as somebody
who who teaches about stoicism who's
written a little bit about it and who
has incorporated some of it into my own
perspective I'll talk a little bit more
about how I'm not a stoic but I'm kind
of like Cicero in this respect a bit
later I wanted to you know talk a little
bit about that in in this video
originally I was going to do something
historical but I think it could actually
be more useful to start with you know
why I'm getting into this sort of thing
why I think stoicism week is a great
thing why if you have any inkling
any interest in stoicism you should get
involved in it and then at the end of
the week I'll do sort of a retrospective
what did I get out of the class kind of
video so again let me you know do you
know just lavish praise on this on this
course on the handbook that they've put
together on the support structure that
they're putting in place with people who
want to learn about stoicism and even
more people who want to start practicing
it and that's really at the core of
stoic philosophy and even the precursor
to stoic philosophy the cynic school
this notion of it's not enough just to
read stuff you have to actually practice
it you have to put it to the test and so
this is a marvelous experiment that's
going on I think that they're gonna
create a community of inquiry that's
already got some you know some seeds out
there but this is going to bring a lot
of a lot of people into to this you know
very important philosophical school so
let me talk about what I'm going to do
as far as videos go this is my
observance of stoical week not not only
being involved in the class and if you
want to get involved in the class
yourself and interact with me that
that's cool
there's a you know for once I'm in a
classroom I get to be the student and
not have to teach the thing so I'll
probably hang back quite a bit and let
the you know the people who are running
it do most of the work there I'm
shooting this video and and as I said
this one is sort of why I'm interested
in stoicism why I think you ought to be
interested in it what it has to offer
and then I'll do a retrospective at the
end of the week on Sunday about you know
what I got out of the course but in
between I'm going to shoot five videos
and there'll be more like my typical
videos up in front of the chalkboard
perhaps all you know do a bit of sitting
here in my office
and they're going to be about classic
texts and thinkers in stoicism one is by
Cicero and it's called stoic paradoxes
and it's it's a great short little text
that introduces some of them some of the
key ideas in some of their starkest form
their most paradoxical forms so that'll
be tomorrow then I'm gonna talk about
Senecas on anger anger is something that
I've been doing a lot of research on in
part because you know it's something I
myself need to work on but in part
because it's a fascinating topic and
Seneca has one of the classic works
where he stakes out a very strong
position on this this emotion that the
Stoics considered to be quite important
then I'm going to look at epictetus --is
and karidian the handbook and talk a bit
about that that's got a whole
fascinating history to it but I'm gonna
talk not only about the history but also
some of the content in it I'm gonna look
at some of epictetus is bigger work the
discourses and I think I will also focus
on anger in Epictetus discourses and
sort of cull out some of the lessons
regarding that emotion but also
regarding broader you know topics like
the race of the relationship between
choice and emotion and our thoughts and
habit all those sorts of things then
I'll finish up on Saturday by looking at
Marcus Aurelius meditations and you know
obviously I can't talk about the
entirety of it that would take us
several different videos but I'm gonna
talk about good portions of it
then Sunday we'll we'll do the wrap-up
so I think I'm gonna do this every year
release seven videos having to do with
stoicism originally what I wanted to do
was the first day would be a video about
stoicism as a historical movement and
then as I started planning it I started
to think well this is gonna get bigger
and bigger and bigger because I always
wanted to try to do things
as well as possible and give as much
detail as possible
and now what I'm actually thinking is
this is going to require several videos
even just just to get from the
precursors of Stoicism to what we call
late stoicism which is not really that
that link because stoicism that has an
entire history after the ancient period
the Christian thinkers engage it to a
certain extent there's a revival of
stoicism and the Renaissance that's
really fascinating it becomes a major
you know tendency and philosophy and
early modern philosophy so that you'll
see Pascale and Hume talking about
stoicism and then in all the way up to
the presence there's what we call neo
Stoics the first neo Stoics were
actually Christian neo Stoics but
there's present-day
neo Stoics who think that this
philosophy has a lot to offer us and
these guys at the University of Exeter
seem to be in that that sort of mold so
I think that would actually take a
sequence of videos and that seems to me
to be something that would be better
done in one of the new channels I'm
gonna be rolling out in the spring a
history of philosophy Channel so that's
enough about videos so let's talk about
stoicism just a little bit and I'm not
going to go into any detailed history
about this because you know again that's
something for longer more more
deliberately structured videos but I do
want to stress one one key point
stoicism is really best understood as
not only one of the major schools of of
ancient philosophy but a Socratic school
and it's not a Socratic School in that
Zeno was a student of Socrates the way
that Plato was or anticipatory Xenophon
or some of the other people who are
mentioned you know as students of his
who actually did you know if not found
in schools that have fun didn't found a
school they at least
you know left us some some interesting
memorabilia about about Socrates but it
is Socratic in that it's descended from
some schools that that do have their
origin in Socrates the the cynic school
and some of the other people who are a
bit eclectic but fit into some of these
other minor Socratic schools and we'll
talk about that in just a second it's
also Socratic in that Socrates is viewed
as one of the ideals he's regarded as
something like a hero figure they put
him next to the Epictetus for example
puts him next to Hercules who is you
know also a model both for the cynics
and for the Stoics of the kind of person
that you want to be and Hercules you
know you think about him he was this big
brawny guy who you know beats up
monsters and and settles you know scores
for four people and does all these
labors what does that have to do with
Socrates who's involved with the life of
the mind
well Socrates by his example is showing
somebody who is able to do in the realm
of morality in the realm of the mind
what it is that that Hercules was doing
in other ways and so Socrates down
through the ages represents to the the
Stoics the kind of person that they
would want you to be now it is a very
stoic picture of Socrates we can say and
what's interesting is Socrates so
impressed people that you could actually
get rival philosophical schools coming
out of him and and being sort of
faithful to him the the skeptics you
know coming out of the Academy
later on looked at Socrates and they
emphasized another aspect of them the
the cynics the the seer attacks the ones
who are devoted a pleasure arguably
left's Socratic but still coming from
somebody who had studied with Socrates
from from eros tipis
so Socrates really is a a central figure
and the currents of philosophy that he
engenders are the matrix within which
stoicism at least early stoicism
develops and I think sometimes that gets
left out of the picture so I want to
just sketch that picture really really
briefly here and what I want to say is
is this so we have Socrates and he's got
all these people involved with him who
we know about in part through Plato and
in part through Xenophon not really that
much other you know first-hand knowledge
Aristophanes doesn't tell us that much
about Socrates diogenes laërtius does
tell us stuff about him but that's you
know secondhand and written down later
Socrates is you know the stem or the
root from which we get the Platonic
school the Academy and of course from
Plato we get Aristotle so the Lyceum so
two major schools of philosophy but
there's also the you know the searing ax
heat in this school coming from Ariston
so that doesn't really influence
stoicism that much but it's it's part of
the backdrop and then there's the cynic
school which is coming from an ticinese
an intestine EES is a very tough guy he
thinks that the only thing that matters
is virtue he says that if you want to
practice that you have to do constant
exercise not only physical exercise but
also what we could call spiritual or
mental or moral exercise that's the
lesson that he took from Socrates and
you know he founds a whole school or a
whole way of life Diogenes historian
dodging easily artist actually wavers
back and forth should we call it a
school or should we call it a a mode of
living and you can see traces of it even
today in the movement
trying to live a simple life there's a
lot of elements of cynicism not not in
the the you know modern sense of you
know sneering at people but in in the
classical sense that we can find in
certain ways of life today and the
cynics have a school of succession so
aunt is the niece has a famous student
Diogenes Diogenes you know he pesters
anta anta student want to teach until
intestine he's actually threatens to hit
him with his staff and Diogenes says you
know go ahead bust my head open you're
not gonna get me to go away and so
Diogenes then begins to study with him
and Diogenes is this very colorful
character you can read all about him I
don't need to go into any details but
Diogenes himself has students and among
these are this guy craft ace and his his
wife hip Archaea and these are the
people that are going to represent the
not only the cynic school but a certain
way of living that is identified with
Socrates and Zeno this guy who's who's a
Phoenician by ethnicity but he's
actually from you know a colony he comes
to Athens and there's a couple different
stories about what happened some people
say he was shipwrecked other people say
that you know you disposed of his cargo
in any case he's in a bookstore and he's
reading Xenophon's memorabilia which is
about Socrates and he says where can I
find a guy like this and the books are
says well you're in luck because there
goes practice right now and so he goes
and he begins studying with him and you
know there's all sorts of cool stories
about what happened you know you know
Zeno apparently it was a little bit more
modest than than crowd taste who was
pretty bold but he studies with with
crotches and he studies for him for
quite a while and these early Stoics
they are these these these cynics I'm
sorry they were engaged in not just
going around and you know offending
people and doing what's natural
but in
in thinking about about topics and
engaging in controversy with other
people so there's this entire matrix
where philosophical schools are now sort
of consolidating and they represent ways
of living now Zeno studies with krottas
he also studies with a few other people
still Poe and Palermo and these people
are coming from yet another Socratic
school the the Megerian school and
they're more engaged in in thinking
about dialectics and metaphysics and but
they're interested in things like the
nature of virtue as well so all these
people leave their traces to some degree
on this guy's you know and he's
crystallizing and consolidating all this
and then he begins to teach and he
begins to teach at the Stoa Waikele and
which you know means the the motley or
painted porch and so he gets associated
with that you know the academy was
originally a place where where Plato
taught and then his school gets called
the Academy the zeno means the people
who are followers of Zeno become known
as the the people of the porch because
that's where they they gather to you
know hear their lessons to to try to
practice what what he's advocating and
it catches on the story gets even cooler
there's more than one interpretation of
stoicism in early stoicism and the guy
who's ultimately going to be the
successor to Zeno is not the brightest
one as a matter of fact he's you know
he's admittedly somebody who has a hard
time memorizing and learning all this
stuff but he's a box or a former boxer
clean up this yeah he really works hard
at it there's a couple other guys
involved with Zeno who could have
the heads of the school who could have
you know taken over stoicism some of
them actually did develop a following
there's a whole interesting story to
tell about them that I'll go into some
other time but what this shows you is
that you know there's multiple ways to
understand this basic set of doctrines
and ideas then clientes has a really
brilliant student who's often called the
second Z no the second founder of
stoicism and that is cruciferous and
unfortunately we don't have anything
that cruciferous wrote he was a prolific
writer Zeno himself wrote quite a few
things clan thinks appears to have
written a few things we've lost much of
what the ancients actually had to
bequeath us but that's you know that's
the beginnings of stoicism these these
early figures but notice that it has its
its context it has its beginnings in
this entire matrix of post Socratic
philosophy and discussions about well
what is the good life and how should we
live and what is the nature of virtue
these guys are thinking about all of
that sort of stuff and then the story of
stoicism goes on through more successors
and it goes into a what some people want
to call syncretic or eclectic period of
middle stoicism you know with with these
these later figures who have to have to
relocate and then stoicism becomes a
Roman phenomenon as Greek culture is
getting important to Rome or really
Romans who can afford to are going to
Greece and you know Greek colonies like
like Rhodes and taking on Greek culture
and bringing it back and so Cicero
himself is is a very important witness
for that Cicero was not himself a stoic
in any sort of doctrinal strict sense
but he was somebody who thought that a
lot of what these guys had to teach was
quite attractive and on some things
Cicero is more of a stoic on other
things he's more of an Aristotelian
even evinces a certain kind of
skepticism from time to time the the one
group that he doesn't really like the
Epicureans that's that's pretty clear
but he's an important figure for for
mediating middle stoicism to us and
telling us about ancient stoicism and
and for representing what stoicism
looked like in this Roman context
there's other figures that we could talk
about to Cato but you know we don't need
to go into that that history right now
and then we get to the period that the
distances and class is really taking the
most material from because that's what
we actually have preserved for us what
we call late stoicism and now we're
talking about people like
epictetus or Marcus Aurelius or or
Seneca and we have you know a lot of
things that these these people left to
us and by then stoicism has really
adapted itself not only to a Roman
context but to a broader I don't want to
say a cosmopolitan because that was
there from the beginning this notion
that I'm a citizen of the world the
world is my city
that's what cosmopolitanism means but
this notion of being part of a larger
economy the the Roman Empire a sort of
culture that that wasn't just identified
with the power structure but identified
with a broader integrated civilization
and there's a whole story - stoicism
after that as well but I'm gonna put
that off for another time I don't know
when I first encountered stoic texts
like Marcus Aurelius meditations or
epictetus and karidian
and I suspect that it was in college
where I first started seriously reading
them but I also think that I might have
run across them earlier when I was
getting ready to go in the army and
when I was in the Army as a young man
right after high school in any case I
found certain elements of stoicism very
attractive and so I'd like to talk a
little bit about some of those because
they may be things that you might find
attractive too
and that could be a good reason to study
some of these authors so one of these is
the notion that we actually have some
degree of control and that means
responsibility for but also freedom in
respect to our our emotions how we feel
about things that's a very liberating
and also countercultural thought in our
own society because we've had a long
time people preaching to us that well
you just feel the way that you do and
what matters is what you do with your
feelings but but your feelings are yours
and they're neither right or wrong and
you just you know sometimes you just got
to go with them and the storks would say
well hold on a second why would you
assume that you just have them that
they're just these serdes that are
imposed upon us and we don't have any
any control over there's a connection
between how we think about things and
how we feel and if we take close
attention to both of those we can
actually start to discern there are some
times where I feel a certain way but I
don't have good grounds to feel that way
and it's actually bad for me to be out
of touch with reality in the way that I
feel about things that's not good for me
that's actually bad for me and my
feelings might be telling me something
totally different at the time like go
with us or were the truth but that's not
necessarily so and that applies to
sadness that applies to designer that
applies to anger that applies to anxiety
all these sorts of things that we you
know take as being
just part of the way things are for us
well no we actually have some measure of
control even what we desire I can't snap
my fingers overnight and and not desire
things that I've been desiring for a
long time so I've built up habits but if
I remind myself often enough if I engage
in a CSIS practice disciplined if I do
this and I say you know those things
that I want to have great example I love
smoking okay not cigarettes I used to
smoke cigarettes for years and you know
I think I understood what I got out of
it at the time there were a lot of
things you know there was a kind of
camaraderie and standing around smoking
with other people you know tobacco goes
great with with beer with coffee you
know it's nice to smoke after a meal
first cigarette of the day Cal look
forward to the feather you know I should
stop talking about this because I'll
probably make somebody want to smoke but
it's not good for you and nicotine by
itself is also extremely addictive right
so you're the physical craving that's
that's partly a matter of your brain
I love tobacco I you know once I started
smoking cigars forget it for cigarettes
and if it didn't have any effects on me
like screwing up my sinuses or making my
clothes stink or you know potentially
giving me cancer down the line I
probably smoked cigars all the time if
it was an innocent pleasure because I
enjoy it so much but I know it's not
good for me and I'm often tempted to go
and buy myself a tin of these ascots
they're nice short little ones just just
a little taste of tobacco and I can tell
myself that you know I know why you're
feeling that way but your feeling isn't
a good feeling for you to have and if
you resist it long enough eventually
it'll be less pressing and that's that's
where I am
currently today thank goodness because
if I do go down that path then I don't
want to smoke all the time and it works
that way with all sorts of things you
know by my videos when I first started
shooting them I was very anxious about
the fact that they were in low tack and
I'd compare them to other people's
videos I don't think these are very good
at all and that would cause me a lot of
not only anxiety but some sadness and
some other negative emotions as well
probably and you know I'll cop to that
and if I change the way that I think
about it what's been very helpful to me
is having other people who said hey you
should think about it this way but if I
if I take on good advice like that I
don't have to feel those feelings so
that's a very powerful doctrine right
there we are not just the the pawns or
prey of situations we have some measure
of control now the measure of control is
actually fairly small we control our
attitudes we control what we have desire
or aversion towards we control how we
think about things and oftentimes the
control is not as direct as we'd like we
have to if we have bad habits it takes a
while to on and you know unmake those
habits and then start forming new habits
but but it is possible for us even you
know one of the words that the Stoics
use for this that Aristotle also uses
but with some of a different tenor is
prior ASIS which literally means to take
something before something else so you
could call it preference I like the
German for naming you know literally
this is the same sort of thing taking
something else before something that
you're you're preferring it to and this
this captures the the the fact that when
we make decisions we're usually not only
making decisions to do something we're
making decisions against the other
possibilities that we have and we're
saying this is better for me than that
or I
prefer this to that and what the Stoics
understood is that price this is not
just something that happens just in a
moment it's something that comprises the
fabric of who we are if you had to pick
you know what it is that a human being
is and you want to isolate it out you
could say our personality but you know
our personality and its most basic for a
stoic is really our Pro a racists and
that's why Epictetus and others will
call it to hegemony con the the ruling
part it can determine itself it's very
similar to what gets called the will
later on not exactly the same is it but
very similar to it and so I find this
this way of thinking about things
incredibly attractive and powerful the
Stoics you know spent a lot of time
trying to think very clearly about how
would we go about improving ourselves in
this way they're not the only ones
Aristotle spent a lot of time on that so
did the plate NIST's I think that all of
them have a lot to contribute so this is
probably a good place for me to talk
about Cicero and why I'm more like
Cicero than Epictetus so Cicero was not
a stoic per se but really an admirer of
the Stoics
and thank God he was because we actually
have quite a few interesting references
to and discussions of the Stoics that we
wouldn't otherwise have if Cicero had
sat down and written he actually puts
Stoics into dialogue with other
philosophical schools in in really
brilliant ways that helped to show us
not only to each school speaking for
itself but each school criticizing the
others so Cicero in some respects he is
attracted to stoicism you know on Duty's
is a pretty stoic work you could say I
think that his depictions of
Stoics in the dialogues like on the
nature of gods are pretty faithful
depictions of the Stoics at the same
time he's also receptive to what he
thinks is right in Aristotle or in Plato
or in the academic skeptics coming after
the the plainest you know sort of taking
over Plato's Academy so you know if you
read a work like on friendship that's a
very Aristotelian work and Cicero is
taking these and he's you know he gets
criticized as being just an eclectic but
the real sense of eclectic is is to
choose out you to take out the parts
that you think are actually the best and
try to form them into a synthesis and
that's what I want to do with stoicism
myself I don't want to be just a stoic
because I love Aristotle too much and I
also love other thinkers too much you
know who if full just the Stoics
commitment would would preclude me from
being able to to work with but there are
some things that I find really
attractive to stoic philosophy and I
love reading their their texts as well
so I'm going to you know probably the
rest of my career be somebody more like
Cicero than then like Epictetus or or
Seneca I I do want to stress that stoic
weak is a really well-organized program
put on by these sort of the center of it
are these University of Exeter people
who have been you know devoting a lot of
time and thought into creating something
but there's events going on all across
the world having to do a stoicism during
stoic week and so there's no better time
than this this present week to buckle
down if you only read one stoic text if
you only read the enchiridion or you
only
a work by Seneca or you only read irelia
TSA's meditations that's progress that's
that's improving your mind with respect
to this incredibly important
philosophical school that still has a
lot of adherents today because it speaks
to us it has a lot to to contribute to
to our way of dealing with concurrent
problems in the world and relationships
and thinking about classic questions
like Who am I what the hell's the point
of all of this
stoicism I don't want to say has all of
the answers or the only answers but it's
really one of the big heavy hitters if
you're going to study philosophy in a
serious way this is one of the
philosophies that you do want to become
at least familiar with enough to know
why you're not a stoic you know or
become a stoic so I would suggest going
over to the the blog you know stoicism
today I would look at the class if
you're not enrolled in it maybe think
about doing it next year they're gonna
be doing it every year I would imagine
you know who knows how long next year
when this comes around look for events
that you can you can connect up with and
look for the things that are available
this week if there's something going on
in your area I would definitely show up
because I've looked at these events
myself and a lot of them look pretty
cool if I was living where some of you
are I would be at those events I think
that's pretty much all I have to say for
this first day of Stoicism week so if
you're interested in videos specifically
about stoic tech so I'm going to be
doing those you just want to hear what
I'm gonna you know have to say after
doing stoic week next Sunday
tune in for that video and if you are in
fact doing the Stoicism week perhaps
I'll encounter you on on the forums